let's see who's next on with us at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty let's go to our caller the Skype
who's calling in via Skype go ahead
hey David this is Oliver from German can
you hear me yeah go ahead Oliver okay
cool um first of all I called in a while
ago I asked you if you have time any
Homa folks in your circle friends I
mentioned Christians but it didn't mean
like that Christians are exclusively
homophobes because you mentioned right
in the beginning of the of the video
when you commentate it is oh okay all
right well I thank you for clarifying
that I was just yeah I was just
wondering because he had like she had
like some of those people like the Navy
chaplain and my science times or some
like that on your show so it was
wondering if you I don't know um what I
was wondering
um what is your opinion on the child sex
offender registry you guys have in the
u.s. I'm in favor of it I mean listen
paper yeah I know that there are people
who say once you have paid your debt to
society
the registry right the argument against
the registry would be if you are
prosecuted for a child sex offense and
yeah five years in prison and you do the
five years in prison you have paid your
debt to society and thus that should
sort of be the end of it there should
really not be any other repercussion and
being forced to register as a child sex
offender is something that is unfair
because if the punishment was five years
and the person did the five years that's
it they've sort of done their thing here
is where I think that just coming up
with like a principal and saying hey
here's my principal and we apply it to
every situation doesn't really work we
know that there is a problematic
recidivism rate with child sex assault
errs so I think that it is perfectly
reasonable to say that as a community
effort we are going to make it knowable
whether there are people previously
convicted of a very particular and and
depraved crime in the neighborhood yeah
is it is it true that in the u.s. people
land on sex offender registry is way too
easy for like the no public of a nation
for example
I don't know but that that would be a
different problem to solve right so that
would if the problem is there that
that's sort of like you know the the
no-fly list right there's two debates
about the no-fly list should we have it
and do we have the right system in place
for determining who's on the list so I
think that you can have a problem with
people who end up on the child sex
offender list incorrectly and still
think that the idea of the list is a
good one you know what I mean hmm I
understand thank you thank you for the
information
thank you she had to go